the michelu tiki burger mcpops onion
rings if you don't recognize these items
from your regular McDonald's menu That's
because you can't get them at a regular
McDonald's in the U.S
they're exclusive to McDonald's in their
respective countries
designed to both attract tourists
America does not have these fries or
wings and more importantly Drive
International sales when you look at the
sales figures about 41 of their sales
are in the U.S and all the rest are
international here's how and why the
company designs those local menus this
is the economics of McDonald's
international
McDonald's founder Ray Kroc opened his
first restaurant in Illinois in 1955
with just three food items on the menu
its staple was a 15 cent hamburger it
first moved outside the continental U.S
in 1967. now the company has over 40 000
restaurants in over 100 countries we
think of McDonald's as an American
company and in the US they have about 13
500 restaurants but the bulk of their
restaurants are actually International
so all the rest of those restaurants
about 27 000 are all around the world
and you may have noticed that the
restaurants look different this is so
Chic there's no Grimace no Hamburglar in
Canada they offer poutine Elizabeth
while Global core items like Burgers and
Fries make up most of McDonald's food
sales still these local menu items make
up about 30 percent International sales
are a key part of McDonald's Revenue
Australia China Japan France and Germany
are a few of the company's top markets
adopting a menu like this is the
strategy companies use called
localization and it's a tactic that has
been essential to McDonald's Global
growth when the company expanded into
India in 1996 it did so without any beef
on its menus observing the common belief
in the country that cows are sacred
McDonald's served more than 6 million
customers there its first year with
items like the Maharaja Mac made with
mutton patties one of India's current
popular items is this the michelu tiki
Burger it's a potato and pea Patty
blended with Indian spices this is Roger
D Dominico he works with local teams to
build International menus they remind me
of of a certain Indian Street food that
I had growing up so I think it's just a
wonderful way to recognize and get
closer to the customers while still
remaining McDonald's most McDonald's
locations globally are managed and owned
by franchisees or licensees rather than
the company deciding what's on those
menus starts with customer research
local experts use that research to craft
new items local flavors are Incorporated
in several ways the first is adapting
McDonald's Staples to fit specific
tastes think if you look at the spicy
chicken McNuggets that have been in
multiple markets each one of those
markets has a different interpretation
of what spice means to their consumers
they'll be one that might be
highlighting Curry there might be one
that highlights more of a tabasco-like
flavor and then a third one that will
use something like a Thai chili or a
jalapeno but some markets will create or
offer something completely new
Mexico has Mick moyetas as part of
breakfast
the Philippines serves fried chicken
with mixed spaghetti
something that tastes like home and can
be both true to McDonald's and true to
the consumer it's a big win for us and
some additions to the international
menus compete with other restaurants in
some of these countries McDonald's
definitely competes with a brand like
KFC on chicken so in some countries in
the Middle East they actually offer
Fried Chicken which is not something
you'd see on U.S menus but to compete
with these local flavors they do that
some of the more popular international
items have even spread to McDonald's
menus globally McFlurry started off in
Canada and now it's loved everywhere MC
spicy is a product that started off as a
local taste variation in China that has
now been adopted all over the world we
want people to come in for the global
core icons we want people to come in to
try something new and so any of the menu
items that we feel like will do that is
what we want to elevate in the system
McDonald's seized on the popularity of
South Korean boy band BTS launching a
limited Edition BTS meal in a number of
countries in 2021 it included sweet
chili and cajun sauces inspired by the
South Korean market the company said the
promotion helps drive a 40 increase from
the year before in global sales and
significantly lifted McNugget sales
during that period
but some transplants aren't so
successful for a number of years
McDonald's has had a vegan sandwich in
Germany and some other European
countries they recently tried offering
what they called a mcplant which was
using a beyond meat Burger in the U.S
and they tested that in some markets and
it just doesn't seem the consumers here
want that so you know there is a push
pull you know it's fun to have new
flavors it's exciting but it doesn't
always work in a permanent way while
having a wide selection of items
globally is profitable McDonald's is
looking to streamline some of its
offerings this year the CEO Chris K has
said that there's just too many
redundancies all across the world he
gave an example where you know there's
70 different types of chicken sandwiches
all across the world and so I think they
are in the process of examining that but
I don't think they're going to eliminate
all local items on menus so next time
you're in Spain you might be able to try
mcpops they're filled with your choice
of white chocolate hazelnut they're
super soft and they've got this amazing
filling on the inside
[Music]
my father referring napkin yeah
foreign
[Music]